Let's discuss a network ideas example,
SNORT.
SNORT is open source, very easy
to configure and very efficient.
SNORT can be easily deployed on most
nodes of a network, including end host,
server, or even a router.
It uses a small amount of memory and
processor time.
SNORT is very easy to learn, and
very easily configured by sys admins.
SNORT can perform real time packet
captures, particle analysis, and
content searching on the packet.
SNORT can detect a variety of intrusions
based on the rules that
are configured by a sys admin.
In fact, there's a community who
maintains a very large set of SNORT
rules that can be further configured
by sys admin for his network.